well what was happening what
psychologically they're just becoming
bored and restless their high sensation
seekers their lesson station seekers as
they were they went to they were fairly
comfortable unless they were had high
anxiety trait there
we measured actually how much they would
move around we could actually measure
their restlessness at the beginning
first three hours there was no
difference but as time went on the high
scream more and more restless twitching
turning you know on the bed they began
to sing to themselves even though they
knew they weren't supposed to speak or
to stimulate themselves they began to
stimulate themselves so that was the
expression if you go a long pair what's
happening in the brain is over longer
periods of time even over shorter
periods is that the the brain waves is
slowing down the basic arousal patterns
in the brain the the alpha waves are
getting slower okay and that the most
people is unpleasant I mean you know to
go below your optimal level of arousal
to beacon for any prolonged period of
time becomes unpleasant if you give them
any kind of stimulation in sensory
deprivation even looking at the
meaningless blotches of color they will
have at least press a bar to do that
know they're being deprived of something
variety and variety of stimulation and
when you deprive people of that that is
very immersive to them okay it's one of
the ways of torturing actually of
putting people it's not just the social
and sensory deprivation when you put
someone you know it's the sensory
deprivation you put people in the
environment they may not be in the
sensory deprivation but if nothing is
varying in their sensory environment it
is becoming increasingly aversive
no it's not humane and it's not and over
solitary confinement that's gold and you
know in prison this one they want to
punish them and they put them in
solitary confinement which is usually a
sensory deprivation as well because
they're even if there's light in the
cell there's no variation okay nothing
is changing no one to talk to you know
part of social isolation is the lack of
social stimulation okay so this this is
over times is very torturous you might
say it's a it's a mental torture of a
sort that's very could be very effective
the torture is often usually isolate
their prisoners before they begin
interrogating them because then they
respond but the tendency to respond to
any stimulation even interrogation
there's more there's more primed by the
leg by the sensory deprivation